tenéis
el senado ha votado para elevar el techo
de la deuda de eeuu hasta diciembre
evitando un incumplimiento a pocos días
se espera que la cámara de
representantes de mayoría demócrata
apruebe fácilmente la misma moción el
martes
eeuu nunca ha dejado de pagar su deuda
pero si alguna vez lo hiciera su
economía quedaría devastada el líder de
la mayoría demócrata dijo que la
reticencia de los republicanos a ampliar
el techo de la deuda pone en riesgo al
país grupo a black inspire los
republicanos han jugado un peligroso y
arriesgado juego partidista y me alegro
que sus maniobras no hayan funcionado
los republicanos sienten que son los que
se jugaron el cuello para salvar al país
de una catástrofe económica pero se
mostraron reacios a aumentar la deuda
nacional y dicen que si los demócratas
quieren hacerlo de nuevo en diciembre y
aprobar el paquete de gasto social
multimillonario del presidente by then
tendrán que hacerlo por su cuenta
la vida que nuestros colegas demócratas
han aceptado evitará al pueblo
estadounidense cualquier crisis a corto
plazo al tiempo que resolverá
definitivamente en la excusa de la
mayoría de que les faltaba tiempo para
abordar el límite de la deuda a través
del proceso de reconciliación 304
el proceso de reconciliación del
presupuesto es una forma para que un
partido presione el techo de la deuda
por su cuenta algo a lo que los
demócratas no quieren llegar por su
complejidad y porque es un proceso
bipartidista que los republicanos
podrían poner en peligro además
significaría que serían los únicos
responsables de elevar la deuda o más
por tanto la crisis se retrasa y las
conversaciones se reanudarán en unas
semanas